more than half of women feel unsafe in
public spaces according to recent
research
a year ago emma k took matters into her
own hands creating an app to help women
feel safer walking home alone the safety
function that we have on our app that
when you're feeling nervous you can keep
tapping and what happens is that alerts
your protector that you're feeling
scared or unsafe and should
anything happened to you which god
forbid it doesn't but it gets knocked
out of your hand that alerts your chosen
protector that something's happening and
your last known location is sent to them
and that's been used 20 000 times since
last six months in the last six months
yeah
the app has seen a surge in use since
sarah everard's murder in march
amid an erosion of trust in the police
after serving officer wayne cousins
kidnapped raped and killed her
the very low prosecution rates of crimes
against women clearly suggests the
system is not working
the number of rape cases resulting in a
charge fell to an all-time low of 3 last
year research found one in 10 women have
been subjected to indecent exposure
but of the more than 10 000 cases of
indecent exposure in england and wales
fewer than 600 people ended up in court
mark fennell's qc says funding cuts to
the cps is partly to blame they
concentrate their resources on what they
see as the most serious crimes the rape
the murder serious violence and things
of that sort and one of the problems
with that is that women tends to be
women give up because the system takes
too long to bring their cases to trial
and they don't feel properly treated
while the cases are being brought
by not tackling lower level crimes
against women it can lead to more
serious offending but there are calls
for an overhaul of policing too
there's an ongoing investigation into
other offices in multiple forces for
allegedly sharing inappropriate messages
regarding the sarah everard case
sexism isn't banter what's needed is
cultural change when it comes to the
treatment of women and girls sally
lockwood sky news